Traductor: Marlén Scholand Cámara
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Thor-hijo de Odin, dios del trueno
y protector de la humanidad,
luchó duro contra su mayor desafío hasta
el momento: abrir una bolsa de comida.
Todo comenzó cuando Thor,
con su ágil sirviente humano Thjalfi
y Loki, el dios tramposo,
emprende un viaje a Jotunheim,
En el camino, se encontraron
con un gigante llamado Skrymir,
quien se ofreció a acompañarlos
e incluso llevar sus provisiones en su bolsa.
Pero cuando hicieron
el campamento, Skrymir se adormiló
y Thor no pudo desatar el saco.
Frustrado y hambriento, Thor intentó
despertar al gigante tres veces
golpeando su cabeza con su martillo
tan fuerte como pudo.
Pero cada vez Skrymir pensaba
que era solo una bellota que caía
y se volvía a dormir.
A la mañana siguiente, Skrymir se fue
y, finalmente, los viajeros llegaron
a una enorme fortaleza llamada Utgard.
Dentro del largo pasillo, se encontraron
con el rey de gigantes, Utgard-Loki,
quien saludó a sus invitados
con un desafío:
cada uno debía demostrar ser los mejores
en una habilidad particular.
Loki fue primero, declarándose
el comensal más rápido del mundo.
Para probarlo, el rey convocó
a su sirviente Logi
y los dos fueron sentados en cada extremo
de un mesa larga llena de comida.
Loki engulló
con una velocidad deslumbrante.
Pero cuando los concursantes
se encontraron en el centro,
Loki vio que su adversario no solo
había comido la misma cantidad de comida,
sino también los huesos
e incluso la propia mesa
Luego estaba Thjalfi, que podía correr
más rápido que nada en la naturaleza.
El rey convocó a un gigante
de aspecto etéreo llamado Hugi,
quien superó a Thjalfi fácilmente.
Pero el chico no se dio por vencido
y exigió una revancha.
Esta vez, Thjalfi terminó muy cerca
y el rey admitió que nunca había visto
correr a un humano tan rápido.
Thjalfi lo intentó por tercera vez,
corriendo como si su vida
dependiera de ello,
pero Hugi fue incluso
más rápido que antes.
Finalmente, fue el turno de Thor.
El rey le ofreció un cuerno para beber,
diciendo que todos sus hombres
podrían vaciarlo en dos tragos.
Thor se lo llevó a los labios
y bebió el hidromiel
sorprendentemente frío y salado
en el trago más largo que pudo.
Luego un segundo.
Luego un tercero.
Pero el nivel del hidromiel en el cuerno
solo se redujo ligeramente.
Para probar la fuerza reconocida de Thor,
el rey ofreció un desafío
aparentemente fácil:
levantar su gato mascota del suelo.
Pero este gato era tan alto como Thor.
Cada vez que intentaba levantarlo,
arqueaba la espalda,
y esforzándose con toda su fuerza
piadosa, solo logró levantar una pata.
Enfurecido, Thor exigió luchar
con cualquiera de los gigantes.
El rey convocó a la vieja niñera
de los gigantes, Elli.
Aunque la mujer parecía frágil,
Thor no podía dominarla
y se volvió más débil cuanto más luchaba,
hasta que se hincó en una rodilla.
Los tres compañeros se prepararon
para partir, decepcionados y humildes.
Pero cuando el rey los escoltó,
reveló que nada en el castillo
había sido lo que parecía.
Loki perdió el concurso de comer
porque su oponente Logi en sí
era un incendio forestal
devorando todo a su paso.
Thjalfi no podía superar a Hugi
porque Hugi era la encarnación
del pensamiento,
siempre más rápido que la acción.
E incluso Thor no pudo vencer
a Elli, ni a la vejez,
que debilita a todos al final.
En cuanto a los otros desafíos,
también habían sido ilusiones.
El cuerno estaba lleno del océano,
y Thor había agotado lo suficiente
como para causar las mareas.
El gato era la serpiente
que rodea el mundo,
y los esfuerzos de Thor
cambiaron la tierra.
Y Skrymir era Utgard-Loki disfrazado,
desviando los martillazos de Thor para
crear valles en las montañas circundantes.
El gigante los felicitó por su destreza,
lo cual lo atemorizó tanto que nunca
los dejó volver a su tierra.
Thor y sus compañeros fallaron
en los desafíos que se les presentaron.
Pero al tratar de lograr lo imposible,
se habían esforzado más que nunca
cambiando el mundo de una manera
que nadie había esperado.